when I see a defense sack the
quarterback
and every d-line then runs up to the guy
who sacks a quarterback and they do a
group celebration I go oh and I don't
want to play again but then I see one
guy sack the quarterback and he's got
his ninth celebration and you know and
none of his teammates celebrate with
them I'm like well he's in it for
himself
you know that's not gonna be that's not
gonna go well over a period of time so
these are just things you guys can see
now you know with just a little
awareness like who are the dangerous
companies who are the dangerous you know
teams and competition that you guys are
facing when you guys succeed is it all
about that person is it about the team's
success I always felt like the
quarterback's job is when it doesn't go
well you take the blame when it goes
well you give the credit that's what
great leaders do you know you always
that's how it should be and